all right we learned overnight that the
US will withdraw all diplomatic
personnel from Venezuela this week as
the country descends further into chaos
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said the
presence of diplomats at the Embassy has
become a constraint on US policy now the
statement interestingly hints at further
US action what could that be that's the
big question
schools and businesses in Venezuela are
closed for a third day because of
widespread blackouts that began last
week men well Bojorquez who has reported
extensively from Venezuela shows us how
the latest emergency is making life
increasingly difficult some desperate
Venezuelans have resorted to sporadic
looting as the typically short supply of
food and medicine becomes even harder to
get they're forced to search for water
too people say since the pump stopped
working the blackouts effect has been
devastating for the country's hospitals
where doctors perform surgeries by
flashlights opposition groups estimate
17 people have died from lack of proper
care
dr. Lise Fernandez spoke with us via
Skype from Caracas
he says doctors are having to treat
patients in their homes as a result of
the blackouts the system has had
problems for an awfully long time
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo blamed
Nicolas Maduro government yesterday for
inadequate management of the energy
system he also accused Venezuela's
allies Russia and Cuba of enabling
Maduro regime the Kremlin is standing
with its Venezuelan cronies against the
will of the people
Moscow like Havana continues to provide
political cover to Maduro regime Maduro
blames a u.s. cyber attack for the
blackouts
though he's offered no proof and so far
no sign he can provide a quick fix all
of this intensifying the difficulties
people described to us as we reported in
Caracas last month when this woman's
grandson had a severe asthma attack the
hospitals couldn't help she said her
only hope
medicine that expired three years ago
you took that arrest until it helped
years ago
for now opposition leader who on why
though
is hoping people channel that pain into
protests he's called for later today
for CBS this morning Manuel Bojorquez
Miami